there was a time when thousands of Iraqi
refugees fled their borders but now
thousands of Syrian refugees are
flocking to them fighting between troops
loyal to Syrian President Bashar
al-assad and the rebel forces has forced
a hundred and sixty thousand Syrians
from their country and here's where many
have turned up the hook in northern Iraq
sixteen people from three families live
in this house a converted animal shelter
Dola Mohammed has been here for seven
months
Dola knew she had to leave Syria when
her daughter was threatened and her home
was broken into to protect my kids I
came here you know back there at night
you could hear a lot of you know
fighting going on happy birthday I read
hard to choose her Mariani band's album
at the fountain then gave its fire and
she her name is John she became a
pleasure every day you could hear you
know airplanes coming and going and then
you know there were a lot of artillery
bombing you know you could hear it and
our house was like moving saving life
this is the Damis refugee camp it's
meant to house 15,000 people but there
are more than 45,000 here now Marwa
darwish bought for two days with her
four children to get here for her the
pain is still raw since you've been here
how has it been is this it's just a
struggle here how is the people at the
camp been decent to her which I worked
it to her t really
this was the Athena host committee Nina
the same way that I work but today
except you see I have a lot to say and
nobody has suffered like me well tell
her to tell us- she bah bah bah bah
Ashburn a bruja del caballo ha ha ha ha
but very homicide I could have thought
of arrest he said I left my brother's
house you know I had to come here it's
much better for me to be here you know
charities say resources are stretched
and they're struggling to make ends meet
it is summertime in northern Iraq it is
43 degrees centigrade during the day
which is incredibly hot for English
people British people just makes us melt
but people who live here it's pretty
damn tough and water is the big problem
not enough clean water for about 160,000
people that are in Iraq at the moment
from Syria as refugees and cholera the
big outbreaks tend to happen in
September so there's a big danger of
that sanitation and clean water and they
need enough money to pay for all of this
much of that money is going to help keep
water flowing in the camp but with new
arrivals expected the pressure is our
our most critical priority right now is
water and sanitation water and
sanitation makes up the bulk in fact
two-thirds of an entire funding appeal
because we're responsible for providing
access to safe water adequate sanitation
in this camp there's a new camp that's
opening in Erbil and even in host
communities the number of Syrian
refugees is expected to more than double
to 350,000 by the end of the year but
with humanitarian agencies having to
provide for so many and no end in sight
to the conflict in Syria is difficult to
imagine the situation improving without
significant financial help Eddie Izzard
Sky News Iraq